Aliens!
We can't do this alone.
I don't plan to.
These things are like World War Z zombies.
Best teamup ever!
It's good there are guys like you to help
the world.
Really did it this time.
Seriously?
Yeah, you ask for my help.
Then we end up the creek!
Heroes vs Aliens, the 4 night crossover event
starts with Supergirl Monday November 28th
on The CW.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
You never guess how Barry messed of this time
so crossover footage lets break it down so
we finally get a look at the dominators they're
like a combination of prosthesis and a little
bit of special-effects but mostly practical
effects.
So you guys can let me know what you think
about them.
when they were initially talking about them
I was had no idea what they would actually
look like on screen.
But they do look pretty good it's like something
out of a John Carpenter movie something with
slime just poured all over it, but the thing
is is we see the flash like investigating
this craashed ship now obviously the flash
is like the first night of the crossover even
though they're going to address it on Supergirl
it's just that they said that Barry will have
to go get Kara bring her back to Earth one
to help out with the threat.
We don't really know how that's gonna manifest
really like their innate power is just their
incredible intellect like their race of geniuses
with a lot of really awesome toys will see
how they try to subjugate the earth and how
close they stick to the comic book plot.
This is all from the invasion comic book storyline
that was written by Todd McFarlane the guy
that wrote the spawn comics so this is all
back from the 90s was a big deep cut but as
with all big comic book plots become to do
their own version of it just because the invasion
storyline in the comics was the like all of
these these titles.
It was kind like a secret warriors crisis
on infinite earths you could've involved all
their titles all the heroes in they can't
quite do that on TV because there couple key
characters that are missing.
So is basically going to be like a big for
our action set piece movie like something
that they could put in a movie theater they
wanted which I'm surprised they did.
They actually did that the first year arrow
and flash of the crossover they aired the
episode like a big movie theater, but that
does make you wonder if the doing something
this big like a big four way crossover this
year have the gonna try and top that next
year will probably pick some other big huge
comic book arc, we can talk about that after
the episode there and that's going to be in
two weeks.
So just reminder about that.
Not next week the week after that the whole
thing is is going to be you know what brings
the dominators to earth does have anything
to do with them shooting that beam of information
out into the multi-verse trying to look for
another Harrison wells we actually see the
new Harrison wells from earth.
19 here meaning that the probably hold off
on Jesse quick and earth two Harrison wells
till after the format crossover maybe midseason
finale or maybe episode 10 for the most part
is far as I know all the main characters will
be involved in the crossover last year they
left a bunch of people out like I don't think
that Iris was in the crossover we had really
met Wally that much yet so there's a lot of
people didn't have on the flash and obviously
Supergirl was on another network that actually
started calling her earth, earth CBS selective
Earth one earth two was 19 earth CBS what
about Deathstroke this is probably one of
my favorite moments in the trailer rages whips
his sword out is like surprised bitches that's
going to be one of the craziest episodes because
it's arrow's 100 episode so they just took
the opportunity to do everything they ever
wanted to do some interested to see how they
try to shoehorn that in logically like you
know there's a mind control element but like
we see Laurel in the pictures here so it's
like okay how do you explain Laurel being
back if she still dead in present day which
is a whole bunch of craziness that I wouldn't
worry too much about until the crossover starts
but I expect when they show up the guilty
of big concepts that will give you an idea
for how the gonna proceed each night but obviously
the last night legends of tomorrow will be
like the resolution of that so that's probably
where this scene comes from like the kind
of demarcate this footage with different characters
hang out together like the legends are hanging
out together in a scene then you have Barry
and Oliver to sing.
I can't believe you messed up this big like
flashpoint was a big deal but this time you
really messed up so I'm really excited that
they even decided to try this like a TV network
crossing shows over is in a big thing like
people crossover all the time.
But this is taking it to the next level like
slowly comic book TV has started to evolve
both Marvel and DC like we have ghostwriter
on agents of shield big a list characters
Marvel is doing a black bolt in humans TV
show on ABC next year, which will talk about
tomorrow, but it is getting crazier and crazier.
So naturally the DC shows also doing the same
thing, so I think that because the dominators
showed up during the Legion of superheroes
story there doing Manel on Supergirl, we will
eventually see them do a Legion of superheroes
story on one of the shows probably Supergirl,
just because they do so much space-based stuff
let me know what you guys think of the footage
and what you think they would do for next
year's crossover.
I think it's still a little early to do crisis
on infinite earth there still a bunch of big
things they could do like war world would
be really cool bit like Mongol trying to invade
the earth would be another cool crossover
like to call this trailer heroes versus aliens
we could do heroes versus war world Abby really
bad ass but just reminder that Tuesday night.
There is new episode of the flash so be sure
to subscribe to get that.
And there's a new round of the giveaway so
all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so the DC
giveaway will run all week is just a $20 Amazon
gift card so I'll just remind everyone when
I post that flash video tomorrow and I will
do that Marvel inhumans TV show video tomorrow
before I post my flash video for you guys
wait for that episode can click here for my
flash trailer and you can click here for my
Westworld theory video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!